[Music]
for me being a part of this movement
gave me that sense of feeling empowered
what i have done with this troupe
has definitely opened up something
that's been dormant in a lot of people
for a long time and that's doing the
right thing
[Music]
they're bringing them in
oh god
i'm out of breath
i don't even walk that far
when you're in a traditional girl
scouting troop it's easy for you to go
to your meetings every week
they can see normal faces that you see
every day
[Music]
when you're in the shelter system you
don't have that
there is no stability
you don't know if you'll be there for
long you don't know when you'll be moved
again
trip 6000 is the first girl scouting
troupe that's solely made for girls who
are living in the new york city shelter
system
[Music]
there are about 8 000 homeless girls
living in new york city who are of girl
scouting age
so for now my dream is to be able to
reach all 8 000 girls
[Music]
please we're going to do our homework
over here
put the paint on that side of the table
this is you see the line here
so that's the mountain yeah
you can paint that and then you paint
the sun
my children and i ended up in a shelter
in 2016 because our home was sold to
make way for new condos that were being
built
trying to find a home in new york city
with five children is almost near
possible
[Music]
i found myself with my back against the
wall and no idea of how to get out of it
so we ended up in the shelter in long
island city
my kids had no one to talk to it about
and felt like they couldn't let anyone
know felt ashamed about it
[Music]
when children are in the shelter system
especially they don't have the things
that they're used to having in their
lives a lot of things are changing
there's no stability for them
so it can it can seem scary
it hurts
you feel in the way that you've let your
children down
even though you've tried everything that
you could when you see your children
like that it makes you feel helpless
so you just have to as a parent hold
yourself together and be as brave as you
can possibly be for them
i worked for girl scouts of greater new
york prior to becoming homeless my job
was to start new troops and recruit new
girl scouts so when i landed in the
shelter i did what i knew best and that
was to go back and ask if i could start
a troop there
i knew firsthand how important it was
for these girls to have the girl scout
experience
[Music]
i will try to serve god to serve god and
my country and my country to help people
to help people at all
at all times to live and to live by the
girl scout law by the girl scout law
excellent all right everyone take a seat
thank you so much
i started troop 6000 in february of
2017.
from our first troop of 17 girls
including my three
we've expanded city-wide we're now out
of 362 girls
[Music]
is everyone holding someone else
[Music]
girls are meeting at their shelters once
a week for an hour and a half same day
same time every week again instilling
that accessibility for the girls
we teach girls robotics to civic
engagement to building their business
with the cookie program
these girls go back to their parents at
the end of the meetings very bright-eyed
and cheerful and letting their parents
know that they've done so much and
that things are going to be fine things
are going to get better
[Music]
it's important for them to build that
sisterly bond to know that they're not
alone
[Music]
my name is sinai and i'm a member of
truth 6000
i have been a member since the very
first meeting
living in the shelter it was very quiet
i didn't have people to play with except
for my brothers
usually i would just play with my toys
by myself
when the girl scouts came i was excited
because then finally i wouldn't have to
be bored all the time
when i started talking to the girls
i started to feel like that i wasn't
alone and i had people dealing with the
same child
[Music]
girls can be whoever they want to be no
matter the
problems they have or the difficulties
there are dealing with
trustee soju was designed for girls to
stay in it no matter if they were in the
shelter or not once your girls go you're
always a girl scout
christina uh jealousy you want chicken
right yeah
okay come sit down you'll see
haley
don't spill it
[Music]
good jelly
i know i'm hungry too
after being in a shelter for a year
we're now living in a home
feels great
but then again i still can't help but
think about those who are still waiting
for their homes
when i was at my lowest and felt like i
had no one there to support me girl
scouting
definitely was there for me
i wanted to make sure that no other
girls felt the way that my daughters did
she taught me how to stand up for myself
and to believe in what i think is right
and to never give up
we're giving them a different type of
family
we definitely want to uplift them and
let them know that this moment in their
life doesn't define them
there will be setbacks in life whether
we expect them or we don't expect them
but it doesn't mean that we're not worth
anything
that we've messed up in life
i want for my daughters and for the
other girls who are in girl scouting to
grow up in a world where the future
is going to be limitless for them
[Music]
[Music]
you